my friends it's one thing to have a
political opinion it's quite another
thing for members of America's top law
enforcement agency to discuss ways to
prevent Donald Trump from being elected
president now we should note here that
struck was removed from the Muller probe
after FBI officials became aware of
these tax but I say there must be more
to the story and today Republicans
demanded real answers from Rosenstein
what's he going to take to get a second
special counsel to answer these
questions and find out was Peter struck
really up to what I think he was the
Inspector General has 500 employees and
a hundred million dollar budget and
that's what he does what kind of text
message do you have to see before you
say it's time for a second special
counsel that we take very seriously the
concerns of 20 members of this committee
or one member of this committee we have
a responsibility to make an independent
determination would you have any any
opinion on the lack of the fruit from
the poisonous tree there might have been
a race to buy a Peter struck well as a
legal matter congressman I can tell you
that if evidence is tainted and that
would raise a concern for me that
typically our cases would be prosecuted
based upon witnesses and documents how
would a straight face can you say that
this group of Democrat partisans are
unbiased and will give President Trump a
fair shake we recognize we have
employees with political opinions and
it's our responsibility to make sure
those opinions do not influence their
actions this is not just political
opinions this is disgusting
unaccountable bias and there's no way
that could not affect a person's work
were you aware of just how biased mr.
struck was no I was not joining us now
for a reaction here in Washington
Republican congressman Ron De Santis
he's a member of that House Judiciary
Committee and in New York is James
Freeman assistant editorial page editor
of The Wall Street Journal and a Fox
News contributor
congressman that was wild there because
he saw Rosenstein in this testimony
today and he looked both a frightened
and he was very defensive
in supporting this Pro
saying look we he checks in with me I
check in with him and and it's all gonna
be okay they're taking care of it were
you convinced well no I mean you go back
to when he appointed muller to begin
with he didn't even identify a crime he
said Oh commis doing a
counterintelligence investigation just
go try to find something so I think he
made a mistake from the beginning he
criminalized politics basically now he
sees in the face of these text messages
we have the lead agent on Hillary who
exonerated her and then the lead agent
on the Russia case saying yeah maybe he
doesn't get elected yeah we're talking
in a nd McCabe's office who's by the way
the Deputy Director of the FBI this is
in the middle of the campaign but we
can't the FBI take that risk
we need an insurance policy to prevent
Trump from getting elected there's one
thing to have a bias there's one thing
to have an appearance of impropriety
this is actually taking a bias and
basically saying you're gonna use the
machinery of government to prevent the
American people from making a choice
that's very disturbing James you wrote
about this today in The Wall Street
Journal and you noted that the struck
email when he raised that issue of the
insurance policy that that really jumped
out at you tell us well yeah it goes way
beyond having an opinion it goes way
beyond extreme bias or even hatred of
the president and his supporters which
is what you see in some of these emails
it it really is suggesting that there
was action taken that I think a
reasonable reading of it is that these
people kind of viewed their role as
protecting America from the consequences
of its political decisions that's not
their job their job is to enforce the
law now I think if there's a more
innocent explanation of this I imagine
mr. struck will have a chance to try and
provide it I think mr. DeSantis
may know better but I would expect a
number of subpoenas coming out of the
House Judiciary Committee to talk to all
of these people we've seen mentions
showing their their anti-trump bias
activism their activism on behalf of of
the Democrats and I think that this is
topic aid for future hearing yeah they
look like they
you know these are moveon.org kind of
activists it's it sounds like it's like
whoa okay it's almost a conspiracy
inside the FBI to do something to stop
this president or this candidate from
gaining steam and congressman De Santis
I want to talk to you on this you you
want some of these people to be to
subpoena the documents aren't as
forthcoming as they should be coming
fast to you to the committee as they
should be but will you be able to get
Peters struck to testify I think we will
eventually so remember Bruce or he's a
high-ranking Justice Department official
he just got demoted because he was
meeting with Christopher Steele who
fusion GPS paid to do the Trump dossier
before the election and then meeting
with fusion GPS after the election oh by
the way the guy's wife works guess what
at fusion GPS so I think you have a
confluence of a number of people in the
Justice Department a number of people in
the FBI knee-deep in the dossier so yes
we need to know who how did they get the
dossier did they pay for the dossier
Rosen Stein wouldn't tell us whether
your tax dollars were used for the
dossier so we need all of those answers
I think struck needs to come in I think
or needs to come in
I think McCabe needs to come in and we
got a conversation is they having in the
offices don't they have like bad guys to
stop like real criminals and real you
know real work to do with the FBI but
they're sitting around agonizing about
whether Donald Trump will win the
presidency apparently and they're like
oh my god he's the worst ever and what
if he wins and we've got to stop it you
Caped Crusader what are you gonna do the
whole thing is just it's embarrassing
for the FBI so all of these people and
James I want to hear from you all of
these people Republicans and Democrats
who trotted out Bob Muller as an
unimpeachable arbiter in a Special
Counsel prosecution or investigation
you could never question him because he
was a Vietnam vet he was bipartisan
respect I gotta say in watching this
thing play out I'm not impressed I'm
just not impressed with how he's handled
us I'm sorry I'm not yeah it's hard to
think of what team he could have
assembled that would give his
investigation less credibility and your
talking about what they're talking about
in the office I mean remember these are
careful experienced lawyers this is what
they're putting in writing in text to
each other you can only imagine what
they're saying about Trump and and their
plans for him when they're not recording
at night but but I think that also that
discussion within the office and it
comes up in the context of them talking
about the insurance policy not sure what
that means
seems to be some effort to keep Trump
from being president Eisen that's what I
might define is a question who else so
we've been talking about struck and page
lisa page getting that FISA warrant
maybe may push on that fund warrant if I
had to guess right now it sounds like
it's something out of homeland or 24 the
old 24 show but it sounds like are you
going to get the Pfizer thing wolf
wolves will monitor what the campaign is
doing and if we have to bring out the
big dogs at FISA will do that I mean the
whole thing job he's probably the guy
who would do that
get the FISA warrant given his car
Intelligence role who knows exactly